Ron DeSantis has announced he is running
for president he filed earlier today and
in a Twitter space uh I we didn't
actually get to hear first because the
Twitter space crashed I think several
times and it dropped down from like 700
000 people down to about like 98 and
that was around like 100 and some odd
thousand I think when he formally
announced that he was running and uh oof
yeah Elon and Ron are getting roasted
over this and I I I'm not I'm not here
to drag out of those guys I think they
did something that was uh it was
interesting launching a presidential
campaign on Twitter was a bold move but
Twitter was not able to handle it they
just didn't have the technology and I'm
and and in this uh announcement you had
this one dude uh what I can't remember a
guy's name David something this uh I
think he's a reporter he says maybe
maybe this is the biggest biggest room
ever and I'm like yeah no uh Red Bull
had like four million people watching
live when the guy jumped from outer
space and we had 200 000 live when
Stephen Crowder was here in January